but there is a clean green energy
solution nuclear power which of course
the democrat geniuses are shutting down
gavin newsom is in the process of
closing california's last nuclear power
station
i was once firmly against nuclear power
not so much on safety grounds but
because of the heavy government
subsidies involved in dealing with
nuclear waste
now it seems those problems are being
solved a new generation of nuclear power
could provide fantastic opportunities
for american innovation and jobs not to
mention a completely reliable and
completely carbon-free form of power
generation and now we're seeing examples
of just how effective nuclear power can
be in the town of camera wyoming for
example a brand new nuclear power
station is replacing a coal-fired power
plant that was forced to close creating
thousands of jobs and many many new
opportunities for the town and the whole
state it is a win for the environment
and a win for american workers in the
heartland this project and more like it
is the kind of energy revolution we need
and it's the kind of thing i was writing
about in a new piece on the fox news
website which is all about how
republicans can actually take the lead
on the environment and turn it into a
political winner in the elections later
this year joining me now is the
co-author with me of that obviously
brilliant article founder and president
of the american conservation coalition
benji backer great to see you benji so
tell us why you think this is um a
political opportunity for republicans
well it's a huge uh political
opportunity here because just like about
a century ago when teddy roosevelt was
told that he had to choose between
preservation and economic exploitation
we have an opportunity to choose not uh
between the green new deal and in action
but a third path forward just like teddy
roosevelt did he chose conservation and
popularized that term and we can
popularize our own agenda that is
balance between economic stewardship and
environmental stewardship that's the
conservative way and we have an
opportunity to do that because young
people like myself are sick of the
divide between green new deal and
inaction and we want a balanced approach
forward and that's what america does
best we just need to pursue it so it's
interesting i completely agree with you
and i was proud to write that piece with
you but um a lot of people a lot of
conservatives and republicans you know
the the minute you even say the word
climate it's got so cut it's almost got
so tainted by the democrats and the in
the extremist way they go on about it
the even just by saying the word climate
you put people off have you encountered
that and what's the solution
absolutely i mean look
climate change has been a polarized
topic for now two over two decades and
it's been taken by the left wing as a
political issue that they can win
elections on but that doesn't mean that
there aren't issues that we need to
solve with our environment and then
maybe they've just gone the wrong way
look a balanced approach is the best way
forward and you if you look at what
americans want we want clean air we want
clean water we want american energy
independence but we should also want
that to be american-led and done in a
way that is
good for the environment and good for
the economy and that doesn't mean that
we have to forego our values to engage
on this issue that actually is the
opposite if this issue of climate change
has been stolen by the left to to win
political arguments let's take that back
and make it our own topic that we not
only win elections on but also create
better policies for the heartland and
the coasts where i grew up in the
heartland this is the type of area in
wisconsin where these farmers and
ranchers need to have a conservative
approach and we need that across the
country yeah
you're so right about that because when
you talk about the specifics that's
another thing you know that you you get
into it and all you hear from left are
these things that really annoy people
you're gonna have to stop driving your
car
we're going to make you have an electric
car you're going to all have drive
teslas or whatever
much more expensive we're going to stop
you cooking with gas you know all the
all the things that you hear
end up sounding
just like punitive and more expensive
exactly and environmental issues should
not depress people they should inspire
people the environment is something that
we all love we all have a personal
connection to the outdoors we all love
this planet and this and this globe that
we live on let's embrace that let's make
the most of it by by bringing an
inspirational approach to the
environment and climate change because
it isn't about doom and gloom it's not
about telling people what to do it's
actually about equipping people with the
best resources to be efficient and
stewards of our planet that is totally
different depending on where you live
how you live and what country you live
in uh let alone what state or what city
you live in so this is something that we
again have been on this false dichotomy
that there's inaction or the green new
deal and that's bad for our environment
and it's bad for our economy so let me
say
this and you heard it here first
this is the year that conservatives can
and will retake the environmental
dialogue because we've led it before and
we can lead it again
and i really really love the way you put
that i think you're completely right and
what's been really inspiring watching
you is the way you've built allies
around this and you know thoroughly
conservative leaders like i'm thinking
of rhonda santos who you've worked with
for example in florida really leading on
this the mayor of miami you've been
really building this movement and we
appreciate that and you joining us
tonight thank you ben benji hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else